hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 14 of my 0 to 100 Mil payto pay
flipping series finally at last I have
finally come up with another episode
sorry it took so long again if you
haven't heard I've been moving and doing
all this other stuff but I won't say it
anymore I just had some real life [__]
to deal with but that has
been kind of not really dealt with it's
half dealt with anyway supposedly dealt
with um but yeah we will jump right into
it
okay so it looks like the black mask
actually has a 12K margin on it h which
is not too bad and I'm just kind of
guessing the Black Mask has a 10
quantity limit on it total guess um I
don't think the limit was in the wiki at
all uh but whatever if we find it we
will add it to our own list uh anyway
we'll go buy it for
564k and uh we'll go for
10 okay so next St will be the Helm of
needs not uh which had about a 1, or,
1500k
not, 1500k 1,500 GP on uh the margin
which is pretty decent and I know the
limit is 70 can remember some of these
now um and we'll go buy 70 of these and
we haven't included a potion flip in our
Series in quite a while so we will go
ahead and add it it had about a um 140
or something uh GP margin on each one
which is still quite nice I should nece
uh near 300K once we buy and sell them
all and it looks like the death Rune
actually has a six GP margin which is
pretty good for the price point so we'll
go ahead and buy um I'm not sure if
we're going to get 10K of those but not
quite we'll go for 8K or maybe a less 7K
all right we'll come back when these
have totally
flipped okay we are back and uh we were
pretty successful this time uh the Black
Mask have nearly sold and got about 14k
on each one which is pretty decent
actually and we will sell them all 10 of
them so we'll get about 144k from that
uh the Helm of KN is not uh we got a
1,41 GP margin we got about 65 of them I
believe and um that gives us about 70
Kish uh the death runes we got a87 GP
margin on which is pretty good actually
for the type of item it is and we got
7,000 of those giving us 50k on the
death runes and the super energy potions
uh we got a 97 GP margin on and 2,000 of
those gives us
194k uh it's not too I think we got
nearly 500k on that flip um yeah so
let's
continue so I think we're going to do
the Helm of Nas not again still has over
1,000 GP margin on it so we'll go ahead
and buy another 70 of
these okay so it looks like the dragon
mace actually has a 6K margin on it uh
which is crazy not sure what the volume
is on these things but we'll go ahead
and buy um oh we could probably do 70 I
guess oh boy I don't even want to talk
about this one
H in total we lost about
290k almost
300K and the majority of that being on
the super energy potions apparently
which
crashed and the dragon mace which
crashed by like 3 or 4k on each one so
not so great uh we made a little bit
money on the death runes um almost
nothing on the Helm of need is not so
overall we lost nearly
300K so that kind of sucks but uh let's
see if we can get money
back okay so the uncut diamond actually
has about 150 GP margin on each one um
which is decent uh it's a pretty fairly
frequently traded item so I would expect
it to do pretty decent and we're going
to put a lot of money into this I will
probably put um maybe 2K of
them yeah I think we'll do 2K and just
see if we can actually flip this entire
thing
okay you can kind of see there the
adamant tight ore has a 64 GP margin on
it which is pretty decent uh we've never
tried this item before but I mean all
the ores are traded quite a bit so it
seems like like a decent margin for the
price uh so we'll go ahead and put 1402
in and do um we do
4,000 so this time around we have done
uh substantially better um we started
off with the diamond flip which went
pretty decent we got 46 GP on each 4,000
diamonds has given us or sorry 2,000
diamonds has given us
92k uh the Adamantite ore we got 60 on
each and 4,000 of those gives us 240k so
the ores worked actually quite nicely uh
we also threw a Super Attack potion flip
in there which was not great H we only
got about 37k from that flip uh but
still not too bad we pretty much made up
the losses from the last flip so let's
see if we can um get a little bit more
money
going okay so we're going to try the
uncut diamonds again cuz they actually
still have a pretty hefty margin on
them okay so next up we're going to do
the mithil ore um it has a pretty low
margin on it but I noticed that this was
um five or six GP lower than the average
price so we'll go ahead and buy it
anyway and uh lastly we'll do some gold
ore as well again um not the hugest
margin on it but it was 10 to 15 GP
lower than the average price so we'll go
ahead and get 5,000 of these as well all
right so the flips are in and uh we've
done pretty decent for ourselves again
um to start off the diamonds uh we got a
55 GP margin each and 2,000 of those
gives us a
110k uh The myther Ore we got a pretty
decent margin on them just not very many
we only got like just over 1,000 of them
giving us
24K and the gold or we did get all 6,000
now but the 7 GP margin will only give
us 56k so not too bad uh we're getting
down to the wire on our membership so we
might go renew it in a second here um
but yeah steady progress not too
bad okay I take that back we'll go ahead
and do that in the next episode but for
now we're going to flip the helmet of
Nas not again look at that 2,000 each
helmet that is quite decent um 70 limit
uh will give us 140k ideally um we might
not get them all but uh best case
scenario we get about 140k so that's
pretty
good and next up we're going to do the
mystal Oregon um again pretty decent
item to do pretty consistently always
has like at least uh 7 10 GP margin on
it and I we do the buy limits worth of
it again and I think we might actually
do um the emerald now I'm deciding what
we should do the uncut Emerald or the
cut
Emerald um but I think we end up going
with the cut Emerald had a slightly
better margin in it uh not a huge margin
but again these are traded quite
frequently so it shouldn't take more an
hour or
two okay and the flip is in and
surprisingly we did very good in the
emerald sometimes kind of hard to
visualize how much the flip is actually
given you um but I did invest quite a
bit of money like 8 mil into the
emeralds um but yeah we ended up getting
a 6 64 GP margin on them and nearly
4,000 gave us about
250k um the Helm of Nas KN we got a
1,000 GP margin on them once again
giving us about
70k uh the death runes we got a 6 GP
margin on and 10,000 of those gives us a
60k margin and the myth Roar we just
broke even on so not too bad um but in
total um we probably got close to 400k
so that's pretty decent and backround
there you might notice we are just go
ahead and buy ourselves another Bond um
but I think that's where we're going to
call it uh for today guys so in total I
believe we made just over a mil uh we
started at about 16.6 mil and we ended
at about 17.7 mil uh so decently happy 1
mil per episode seems to be the standard
um unless I get kind of Lucky so anyway
hope you guys enjoyed and I will see you
guys in episode 15
n
[Music]